did you see the Revenant yes how did you
like it I don't think it's in urichu's
one of his best films I I think that
when you look at at the Revenant for me
and you look at
you look at Leo DiCaprio one of her
truly most talented actors that we have
today I think that he in every
performance is going to be exceptional
or better and when you look at that
being his Oscar when you're like that's
a shame because it's the Wolf of Wall
Street I mean if you ask me what's the
best Leo performance it's Wolf of Wall
Street it's not Revenant and that's the
the thing sometimes when when uh when we
have those discussions about what was
the best performance and it turns out
that I don't even think the Revenant was
his best problem let's say it's a bad
one but it's like that's the one that
we're going to pick for the Oscar
um Blood Diamond sorry yeah I mean
listen you could name so many right uh
but I mean Wolf of Wall Street again
there's pretty much a perfect film for
me a three-hour film that is literally
one of the funniest films what a comedy
uh and yet so poignant about all its
points about the excesses of the rich
but but when you look at the Revenant I
just remember seeing that film one of
the first screenings of it and uh the
weird thing is when you go to see a film
like the red
and you come out and everyone is raving
oh this is the best film I've ever seen
and you go
did we watch the same film because that
happens and you you go are they right or
am I right you start to doubt yourself I
go back to the five Bloods the five
Bloods was a film that
I watched on a screener that was right
in the middle of the pandemic very early
on and Netflix had these huge hopes
Spike Lee black Clansman oh man what a
film I mean you want to talk about
recent Spike Lee films black lanceman's
a million times better than the five
Bloods but I remember reading the
initial uh thoughts the social reactions
to defy Bloods the morning I the the
Embargo broke and I had my tweet ready
to go and I looked and I go
what the hell am I looking at like I
looked at my tweet and then I looked at
what I'm reading I'm like Masterpiece
this movie's forgettable Master P what
am I I said okay I sat there for a
moment with my draft tweet of the review
of defy Bloods so and I said do I want
to send this am I going to get like
what's going to happen with this so I go
[ __ ]
sent and then of course people ah look
at this he doesn't know what he's
talking about but here's the thing
ultimately what happened with that film
was it a huge officer Oscar success no
the fight Buzz wasn't
you have to stay true to your initial
thoughts on a film and not be persuaded
to think otherwise and that's that's
hard because in there's people that are
going to come after you and say you're
wrong I'm not a huge fan of everything
everywhere all at once
and I have my reasons I think it's
excessive I think it's repetitive I
think it's over long there are people
who think it's the best movie ever made
or up there okay and you have to stay
true to what you believe and as a film
critic evaluator anybody whatever your
opinion of a film is is your individual
subjective opinion that said if you look
over the track record of of somebody and
I think hopefully this is something I've
earned over the 10 plus years I've been
doing this is you have a track record
did this person which which side of the
coin were they on on this film were they
on the up down and and if you look over
the track record of your evaluations
your critiques of films if they are
largely where everyone kind of lines up
on it not that you're trying to do that
but if you are then then I think that's
that's key too because if you're always
on one side that's completely different
from everybody else that's different but
I think the other challenge is a lot of
people want to again end like a Spike
Lee with the five Bloods you you'd say
this is Spike Lee so it's got to be good
no why
why just because it's Spike Lee just
because it's director whoever name any
director Nolan Fincher anyone currently
working today
um
any director uh you have to look at that
individual film The Past does not
indicate the future you can't go say
this is because every film they ever
made was good this one is and I think
the five blood is a great example of
that it's it's not a great Spike Lee
film and I stayed true to my thoughts
and I think over time I've been
Vindicated I think we can get bullied
into something you know you didn't like
the following versus Inception yep I
like smaller films but but it's not
something that you want to raise your
hand really and and pronounce to the
film Community well you you do you're
gonna get bullied I mean even everything
everywhere I uh I sent a tweet after I
saw it I heard it was just so great
everything everywhere all once and then
I I sit through and I'm like man this is
extremely repetitive at the end
um they are bashing you over the head
with the same joke the same thoughts uh
almost an
it's just it's it's too much it is an
overload on the back end of that film
and I really it's funny that's a film
talk about a film I turned against it
was a film I felt great about everything
everywhere I was like I like this film
and then oh man it's the diminishing
returns and I started to go really down
on that but I sent a tweet out saying I
think this is
I want to start a a new group called
everything everywhere all at once is
overrated but I'm afraid no one will
join me because they're afraid to admit
it
Well turns out one of the Daniels jumped
on and said yeah snarkly funnily oh I
agree with you we agree it's not a good
film like okay but what's interesting is
after that whole exchange I didn't think
anything said I'm not going to change
I'm not going to delete the tweet this
is what I believe what the director says
you know did I anger the director I
don't know but but you have to be strong
in your convictions fearless and not
worry about what other people think of
you you know I go back to Cisco neighbor
which I grew up with watching that show
at the movies uh you know every Sunday
on PBS I'd watch that show and Gene
Siskel is my film critic hero of all
time I mean I I think that he his mind
and how he evaluated films watching him
and Ebert go back but especially Cisco I
would listen to that man talk and I'd
say what a smart film person I want to
be like Gene Siskel one day and one
thing that he was was very adamant about
sticking to your original thoughts on
something never wavering and they have a
great exchange between the two of them
where he talks about the death of a
Critic so the death of a Critic is
wanting to be light wanting to fit in
wanting to be part of the group being
afraid of saying what you believe to be
your experience with this film and like
a lot of critics have an issue with that
because they don't want to stand out
they're going to be like whoa wow you're
the guy who didn't like everything
everywhere all at once yes I am and I
have my very specific reasons why and
I'm not going to be bullied off of that
platform
and that takes uh you've got to be
strong you've got to be fearless and go
I don't even care you just mute the
replies on Twitter I've done that plenty
of times well a lot of film music art
people are on the fringes anyways yeah
we're kind of used to it yeah maybe
that's how we were in high school so
okay great that's how it is now 100 how
I was yeah
um it's funny I had an exchange with my
friends last last night
um and we were with the hustle Premiere
and he said I think a lot of people on
Twitter they they think you're like the
bad guy the film film Twitter bad guy
because you're like the mean jock from
high school and I'm like that is so
funny to me as you say that because I
was a nerd I was a full-on geek okay I
you're back to Anthony Michael Hall and
16 Candles that's who I was okay kind of
in between not really cool and not
really totally a nerd but definitely not
with the cool jaw kids and but I think
that's the power of I think that's who I
am that's your power is that you're not
really one of anything you kind of can
belong to any group and I think we need
to do more of that is is to to be in the
same with films do not just ingest
Marvel product do not just ingest four
quad films go out and look for that tiny
film that will move you that gets you
excited about Cinema again I go back to
last year a very small film from Tim
Sutton funny face oh I mean that is a
film that I have watched that film I
have the Vimeo link to that and I have
absolutely exhausted the Vimeo views on
that I've watched it so much because the
mood of that film and the direction and
it's something I would have never
watched in the in the studio said hey
will you watch this movie we believe in
this film it was gravitas Ventures and I
go yeah it was it was like during
there's nothing else coming out I said
let's see this I'm so glad I hit play on
that because that was not theatrical I
had to watch a screener but that's what
you're looking for when I watch funny
face when I watch
Saint Maude when I go to we the animals
I'm these recent films they're tiny
films well Saint Maude's obviously 8 24
but we the animals these are films when
you watch like wow this is what I love
and you know it when you see it it's
just the artistic quality of the film is
so high
and and those are those are the things I
mean it's just like just vary your
cinematic diet do not just take in one
kind of film see as much as possible and
uh and stick to your guns ultimately
stick to your guns or whatever you think
and whatever you believe in Champion
okay so that being said you wanting to
stay true to what you believe in not
trying to please other people and say
okay I like this do you listen to film
critics and base what you see no you
don't okay never in fact I don't want to
I don't want to know
um a lot of times we're lucky enough to
have seen one of the first screenings so
there's not a lot of reaction out there
so we'll see you know Dominion I see
Jurassic world Dominion on Monday night
it comes out Thursday so I'll have I'll
see it where there's really not a lot of
reaction about it so my my reaction to
it will be all I have I don't have
anything else to base on I don't want to
in fact when there's a film that's
already debuted let's say it's Sundance
I didn't go tell your ride Venice any
Film Festival you name can I I'm gonna
not like Elvis is a great example comes
out here at the end of the month I don't
want to know about Elvis I've heard
Austin Butler's amazing you can tell
from the from the trailers that he
nailed this but I don't want to know
anything else because I don't want to
have my opinion altered by someone
else's opinion so I try to avoid it as
much as possible it's weird to me that I
hear there are people and I've seen this
I'm not going to name names there are
people who in Social reactions coming
out of a screening like say at Sundance
have actually looked at others you can
very clearly tell they cherry pick
things and put it cobbled together and
put their own reaction together if you
aren't able to come up with your own
thoughts about a film that are
absolutely organic with you and not
originating from someone else then you
shouldn't be doing this you should only
care about your specific reaction to a
film I don't ever want to be influenced
by somebody else and that comes back to
being strong in what you believe in and
knowing
trusting your instincts
so same thing with music if we go back
to let's say the 80s or whatever and you
know whatever hit boy band of the you
know just just being strong in the fact
that I I'm sorry I can't
you know we've come up with a lot of
names I'm sure but you know guilty
pleasure sure but but something that's
on the fringes and being okay I'm a
fringe person oh and I'm I own it oh I'm
flying my freak flag I don't care 100
and that's part that that's part of the
fun I mean like I said when I was a kid
I'd go I'd go to the record store and
I'd say they'd have the top 40 singles
sitting there and I would look at number
one and I go nah that's I've heard that
a million times let's go down to number
40. and let's take home number 40
because I haven't heard that and I was
always looking for the more obscure
thing and I think that's even for me
nowadays when I go well I really want to
watch things that haven't gotten the
attention they deserve ultimately
um they're rare I mean let's be honest
not every small film is worthy of
attention certainly not every large film
but the ones that are I think it's our
job to get the films that deserve
attention that are smaller and not
receiving any oxygen pump them up let
let's get those let's give them a Runway
people have sent me tweets saying hey
Eric I think your service is really
valuable when you recommend something
that I didn't even know about and I
think that's the power of of what we do
is being able to bring eyes to something
that perhaps would not have them without
you saying that this is something you
need to put on your radar okay so you're
not promoting the soundtrack from Frozen
yeah okay there's no way no way but but
you know as I say that you can come out
of topic on Maverick and have the same
reaction which is completely populist
everyone you know as as American apple
pie film making as it gets but
it still is a great film in what it's
doing and I think so you can't just say
because it's big means it's bad
um so you have to watch that too I think
a lot of people are like whoa if it's
not some small Indie then I don't it
doesn't have any value I'm like well
let's try to just have a film being a
film period period regardless of budget
regardless of Studio
whoever's directing who's ever whoever's
in it the film has value as a film
um that's it that's you have to look at
everything that way